hello everybody welcome to part 13 of
resident evil 8.
um there will be another jump here
because i just walked back to this area
uh from where i had last saved at the
duke because we'd already done it all
i crafted some handgun ammo and i also
for anyone who didn't know
uh got an achievement brilliant
got an achievement by shooting one of
the guys who was on one of the hangar
things
um so i just bought two like jetpack
guys in here
and that's really all i've done it's
probably a lot of looting to be done in
here if i'm being perfectly honest but i
also noticed that the fans have
orange on them that i suspect that i'm
going to have to shoot
but i'm also [ __ ] you don't have
anything to loot
a little bit scared um
like this is all red why are you so red
um i'm sort of worried that as soon as i
shoot it
it might fall or something i mean i'm
gonna be like forced out of here
oh for what purpose is that
for none purpose excellent great
cool love that for me back [ __ ] up we
go
yeah i don't know everything's red in
here and i don't know why
because i can't see anything that i'm
missing and i hate it
and it's the worst day of my life
and also this is suspiciously calm there
is no way
i'm not going to get my [ __ ] ass
kicked in here any minute now
you got nothing you just hold there we
go okay we'll take a crate thank you
okay sue
the sweaty start shooting them maybe
no okay okay cool okay that's great
a little bit further down i'm thinking
i probably just didn't aim at that one
correctly
you oh it's the inside got it
bloody hell and then there's gonna be
the one on the other side
still one nope on
the other side
this one right here i'm scared did
something bad's gonna happen
no it's fine
it's just stopped okay
see now it's all blue maybe that was all
i had to do
i'm just gonna make sure we check
downstairs
to make sure everything
is blue i don't know what his [ __ ]
voice is beautiful
well this voice i'm doing today is it's
like mcgonagall but
but very extreme um
again i yeah i've been locked up for a
while man it's
i've been locked in this hotel room for
like 13 no
it's gonna say 13 days no it's nine nine
days at this point
um okay
up we go i think i'm looking for
something to create a mold
or something to potentially build a key
because that engine room still has a big
old exclamation mark on it or at least
the the
maybe it's not called the engine room
the the
no i don't like any of this oh it's so
open oh god
this looks like it's just
everything about the resident evil 2 lab
looks like this
beautiful get me out of here
okay i might have just been saying
something and if i was i've already
forgotten it so
that's where we're at
cool let's go
okay is this one of the same boot again
or is this a different boot no i think
it's the same boot
oh great okay there's gonna be a whole
extra area
sold out jet attached to jet pack and
head stabilizers to assault out greatly
improves mobility experience through
limited flight capabilities no long
distance light but now possible to
navigate a rugged terrain
sold at panzer uh attached to aluminium
it doesn't say that but that's how i say
it alloys shielding to sold out to
protect chest reactor and expose flesh
invincible against regular firearms
i think i already read that anyway cool
thank you we love ken fluid huge [ __ ]
fan of ken fluid dude
this is like some of the best [ __ ] just
give me more of it you know what i'm
saying so it's gonna make me fight
explody boys so i should maybe just even
put the
handgun away for good
oh god oh [ __ ] scared me
yeah yeah yeah okay buddy i don't
i don't know that we needed to i didn't
push you the whole way out there
oh my god [ __ ]
that was good yeah well whose fault was
that ethan [ __ ] hell
oh hello there my my aren't you pretty
oh my gosh [ __ ] yellow quartz
oh oh oh hello
there's a goat of warding oh it's right
there how did i
uh we're just going to pull out the
knife for that one
and and then um sorry about that that's
awful
we can't i'm just playing around
okay they click this [ __ ] oh it goes way
better it's okay it's okay it's okay it
might not be
it might not be in here
yep
all right right oh
did i see it as being red when it wasn't
what wha
oh my
oh oh oh oh oh oh
this this seems dangerous
uh ethan i feel like this is a bad idea
but uh okay i really thought that that
was steam
and i don't know if you've ever had a
steam burn but that does not [ __ ] around
all right
am i going to be able to get back yeah
i'll be fine
okay cool what could go wrong
can fluid for me
i don't love that
why is there so much noise in here
does this interact with the bowl no
okay let's roll soon
she'll start her ceremony with your rub
i did
help her with that yeah if that happens
it's all over
for your kid and for the whole village
but don't worry i'll stop it
is he going to say miranda to kill
miranda
oh he said miranda that time
poor papa you're the only one who
doesn't see your kid's
i agree ethan's a [ __ ] i'm on your
side heisenberg
i'd like to see you try what leg do you
have to stand on with that ethan
who are you [ __ ] kidding you gave
them all the parts and that now you're
locked in this factory
[ __ ] this dude it's a god i'd like to
see you try with what bargaining power
can you say that with that much
confidence you
[ __ ] idiot i'm getting i'm getting a
bit salty
about him at this point there's
something swinging in here
hello my friend um
yeah i'm at this point i'm a heisenberg
stan
mother miranda ha ha
she'll take your rose and she'll
i don't know [ __ ] ah sick she'll
find whatever's left in this room
is it gonna be glowy is it a glowy thing
oh it's probably just this in it
open please yes thank you
um i feel like if i listen to him more i
could probably nail his voice pretty
well i think
if i'm being honest
we could mimic some of that okay all
right back out in the open are we oh i
could probably just it's probably just
going to take me straight back now
oh in mine
this is red what the [ __ ] am i doing
today
i don't know what's going on is that the
part that it's telling me
that's interesting
oh ethan there's more
there's so much more and we i want to
get over there fam what's going on over
there
that [ __ ] looks dope
all right oh is this going to be the
duke again
or just power to the duke maybe
i think it is all right
so what's up with this then is there
ah
that feels dodgy but i suppose we're
doing it
um i'm gonna take that and we're gonna
just take all that and we're gonna sort
of just take a little quick little look
around here we're gonna take that
we'll see beautiful and we're gonna
slide over here
let's [ __ ] go let's do this
okay we got food
we where you got we ah
who's that all right
i'm out of focus come on buddy you got
it
boys hand always fixes it um
okay was it the duke yes i feel like
i've seen him very recently because i
did the whole loop back when i didn't
save
thing feel free
thank you my king yeah
not yet still don't know what that's
actually for though
that's all you can really have
food is life technically true you do
need food to live reload speed
you could do the rate of fire on this
or reload speed or ammo capacity
i think it does make the most sense to
probably
do that i don't care about the [ __ ]
reload speed though
maybe i should save or this
i do like ammo capacity i think maybe
that is what we do right now
delighted too thanks mate all right
i don't know how i feel about that
purchase anytime
but it is a thing that i did okay
so heisenberg's factory
we have to go back to b3
maybe it's b4 i don't know it's bloody
one of them
i think it's probably it was probably b4
but i still don't have oh my
oh don't mind if i do that while i'm
here um
i have the key mold i saw this great
family photo
i still don't have the ball and i don't
have anything i can combine that with
hmm
i went to the wrong floor
let's go all right
cool it's this way
it's dark oh no it is dark
oh [ __ ]
thanks for pointing that out though
ethan [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] oh this feels like
doom three
what the hell is this what is dead space
this is spooky
i i like how i said that like i forgot
that i'm technically playing a horror
game
because this feels so much like an
action game
some's going to scare the [ __ ] out of me
is it still all blue though what do i
[ __ ] care
i'm a king in these parts
okay so everybody said that everybody
just stayed there
where am i going
ah yes this is that room that i oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] dick
that i spent my whole goddamn life in uh
maybe i should just do that
[Applause]
probably wasn't necessary but
you know why not that's where i found
that quartz i hate this room
oh the factory really screwed me in a
lot of ways in terms of
time finding [ __ ] it's so spooky
in here is another one going to come out
because of that thing again
i think i'm going the wrong way though
where the [ __ ]
i'm trying to get just to the foundry
right
i don't know how to get there it's it's
back out that way and down
i think excuse me
i hope that i'm correct
oh uh damn damn downstairs downstairs
for me
don't love this don't love any of it
oh my god okay i don't know where you
are
oh my god what in the [ __ ] how how in
the [ __ ] dick
that was [ __ ] rude mate
in the chest no in the chest
okay he died a lot faster than some of
the others have died
maybe i'm not shooting them as in the
chest as i sometimes think that i am
this is the only goddamn red room in
here but i assume it's because i have to
cast
we are going to cast a key
show your faces you don't be sods
come out you know it's perfect time i'm
gonna wait for this thing to finish it's
the perfect time to jump me
okay that's it that's it that's it
this room is still red how dare you
still be red
maybe i'm gonna need to cross the bowl
in any case heisenberg is directly this
way
do you think that we can make a deal
because i still don't want to fight this
man
just so we're all clear
i don't love this for you
you hanging out with [ __ ] zombies in
here dude
you sure [ __ ] are
you just did this to clear out my
[ __ ] inventory didn't you
video games rude as [ __ ]
stay down okay you did stay down you did
stay down
you also stayed down oh they all stayed
down okay great
okay well
i'm not seeing any this is his office
this is his quarters oh what the hell
dude
this is pretty weird mate this is
not really what i imagined um
but all right you know
whatever gets you off ah
i wonder what i'm supposed to be doing
with these two oh my god oh my oh my
oh my god everybody i'm so sorry that
you had to see this
jeez what's gotten into me
just disgusting
it makes sense for me to move those down
there and that up there and then swap
these two right
yeah okay good okay and then just
oh my gosh i'm so sorry oh i actually
came in
to combine those two things it is
uh these two right
that's what i was doing this whole time
making this hammer
could have fooled me and it is not a
weapon
yes no
um okay what am i supposed to do with
just sell it um all right
uh this room is looking pretty done to
me
why did i do any of this
and have i actually missed something in
this room
i don't think there's anything else me
to cost
can't use it without a mold oh right
yeah no i knew that um
maybe i have missed something in here
what was the music
oh gosh so
i suspect what's happened to you
is that
this is only still red because i can
still use the casting machine even
though i would have thought i was
done and i'm trying to see if there's
anywhere at all like that's just because
it connects to there
that i've not
what is this
that's an unexplored room that's
unexplored
so there's an entire room that i've
missed
which um looks like it's just on the
other side of the
shaft
so my guess is that i've done everything
and now i'm scared to walk out because i
think that i've unex
i've missed a room [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] dark ass place
um let's see if we can go back to
whatever that is okay
okay controller i feel you vibrating
oh big boy yeah
it sure is sure is
i think i have some minds probably still
dude even this stuff doesn't bother me
okay let's throw some mines down shall
we
are you that invincible bro okay no he
actually should be killable now i think
because we we broke his chest open oh
god
hopefully
nope they're pretty easy to dodge
all things considered okay there we go
okay
great thank you i probably overdid that
one
i needed to just break his armor off and
now i've gotten rid of
most of my explosives
the situation is not necessarily ideal
i'm just trying to go back to that room
that's all i'm trying to do
please just let me leave just let me
leave just
[ __ ] another one [ __ ] dude
i do have some splosie some spicy spices
that no yeah that's okay okay
all right bro just [ __ ] chill out
would you just let me shoot with a
[ __ ] stupid chest
one more come on open up give me a hug
give me a hug give me a hug give me a
hug
one more okay come on come on me i'll be
right back
okay hugs mohawks hug hug huh hug
how's that no more okay okay buddy
avocado you're good to have a cuddle
back into a corner here it's not great
for [ __ ] sake dude
[ __ ] you know oh that's his arm how
about that
i would just like you to just stay down
or hug me
yeah [ __ ] me
okay cool perfect
that's a huge compliment for you dude
somebody called you perfect
okay it definitely wants me to go back
this way i'm really worried i've made a
mistake
i made a mistake because i didn't
explore a room
and now i'm worried that something's
going to be triggered uh what floor is
it on does i have an unexplored crew
i think it's on the very bottom isn't it
no no no no no no
no no no no no no it was the top it was
the top
it was the top and it was next to the
ventilation shaft which i'm hoping that
i can get
back into i can't believe we made it
but really it's
here
somewhere here
oh sneaky sneak oh my
um okay
i don't know what's gonna be in here
you're gonna give me
i'm just assuming that it's something
that's gonna go in that mold so i can
make that room unread unless i am
missing something
oh my gosh
oh oh [ __ ] that's gonna
do me the labyrinth great
okay we've done it ah
let's get out of here go make the ball
mold
in theory everybody should be
dead dead anyway until i go through
the daughter heisenberg who i'm really
hoping i don't actually have to fight
because that dude
[ __ ] for sure that i don't have you
seen
he's like a magician i don't
want anything to do with any of that i
still maintain that we should
consider a truce um
my god all right i'm once again going to
teleport to
us making the mold it's ball molds time
if this room doesn't go blue after this
i'm going to lose my [ __ ]
that's what this whole playthrough has
been and i really feel like i need to
play this game a second time and not
care about this stuff because i'm so
much more focused on turning rooms blue
than anything else it's not great
so yeah i'm totally gonna play through
it again when i finish it and just not
care
okay that's gonna be for the labyrinth
thank [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i really could have missed
that though i'm glad i looked um
okay just come back out
everybody should stay dead i'm pretty
sure
they're bloody better
and we've got through here and back down
here
and through here very spooky hallway oh
so red it's a very scary hallway oh my
and then it's just the door to the left
let's do it clearing the map out i think
this is basically this whole place
done cool
okay
oh i couldn't even see where it was all
right i'm gonna move you around okay
make sure you don't fold that way
okay yeah great cool great yeah sick
go go go go
didn't deserve that but i'll take it
okay fall down
um oh there's a little card at the
bottom
okay make sure you don't fall off mate
that oh i [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up
all right okay troy again
shall we
there's this um vr game that i played
ages ago that had like
environments like this but in vr you
could physically like
change your height so you could look
around it properly and i keep wanting to
do that
like you could like make sure you were
in between levels by moving through the
vr
these always uh just make me think of
that okay
see it's [ __ ] is there a camera
control that i'm not seeing
there is well
that'll help i think
good to know that that exists
take you out here and push you through
this way
beautiful great daniel bloody go mate
okay probably slow down a bit
just a touch [ __ ]
hottest puzzle in the entire game
okay
cool great let's go
let's keep going buddy
slow you down as you get to this crank
is what i would like to do
okay dude okay let's go let's go let's
go okay
just everybody just slow down a bit you
know
oh my
this wouldn't be super hard if i didn't
know that you could turn
oh the timing no okay we got it
oh it's on a tilt anyway oh my gosh ball
don't fall out of there now oh my
oh maybe that was meant to happen
okay yeah okay this seems fine you pull
down there
and we'll take you back this way right
yeah the training problem is just for
aesthetics
hey all right i got [ __ ] to sell
where you want all this garbage i
[ __ ] got i think i have it yes
yes yes
so you could have two of those you know
one of the two perfect ones
you can have heisenberg's hammer you can
have the skull
and that's actually all you can have
so enjoy yourself this is something to
splurge on
food is live not what i meant to press
there
uh wasn't there another upgrade in here
and i already buy them all
i did okay so i like the shotgun the
most probably
i barely [ __ ] use this thing uh
gonna maybe and i know someone was
telling me about ammo capacity
but i i'm fine on ammo so it would be
exploration but hang on i'm just
checking my ammo mate
i think that's probably not worth me
stressing about um
what we're gonna do we're gonna do this
we make it more strong application can
be done in just a moment
yes we make it strong
uh i don't care about really well
[ __ ] dude that shotgun
oh my god the magnum's so strong
that shotgun is a lot stronger than even
the sniper rifle
which is crazy to me um
you know [ __ ] leave this to me buddy
bloody [ __ ] why not then this is all
an investment
we'll just do a bit of that just oh but
hang on hang on hang on hang on hang on
hang on because i used
you know what so many
just because and then let's hang on
let's see where we're at real quick
have a wonderful adventure thanks king
um i think maybe we go another mine
maybe more mine maybe
as you would i would really like the
shotgun ammo though so
don't have any anyway um okay mine
oh excellent i'm surprised that that
didn't sell out there
what can i craft i have a wonderful
adventure you can do that
and so we will uh
one more mine welcome i think i can
afford one more
how are you still not sold out it's
making me nervous that you aren't sold
out and i'm
please come again should i get the
sniper ammo instead which does more
damage
examine doesn't tell me how much bloody
damage it does
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the tie
i'm gonna do the sniper emblem
great now we're paul but i feel good
about patronage
i feel pretty good about it i think
we've made some correct calls here today
so let's go
back to the top i believe
okay oh
that was a cat that was a goat there was
a goat
i there care enough to waste ammo on it
though i'm sorry goat
that's how [ __ ] unimportant you are
to me i'm sorry mate you're gonna have
to take the l
alrighty let's do it
i'm gonna go make friends
with my best friend heisenberg i'm
really excited tough one
thank you but i'm tired of chitchat
time to die i was still holding out hope
that we could
count you oh it's gonna be fan man my
buddy fan man
fan fanboy oh sure is sure is
okay um
maybe it's a similar oh oh god
okay he's breaking down walls
there's ammo in here that means i
have to shoot him oh i see
hang on [ __ ] gun in time did you even
okay okay so we're gonna run into [ __ ]
maybe i have to get him to break the
walls down for some specific reason
and we shoot him in the back
so many missed shots i really should
have chose something that has
maybe even a handgun i'll do something
with some kind of better rated fire
come at me king now you're on fire
now you're on fire okay oh my god what
the
what in the [ __ ] where have you gone
mate oh my god
oh my god ethan ethan moon ethan ethan
mook
okay is he still gonna run into walls
though
oh he sure is he sure [ __ ] is
why is he running away buddy you don't
need to do that i'm your friend
i wonder if maybe there is a damage
thing though and that maybe my
my thought process here is
uh i need to hide from the flames is the
wrong one maybe i should be using the
shotgun
because i'm like well you just have to
shoot it but maybe it does require a
damage meter
just dodged in real life hey what the
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god when did he get so fast
i would really like you to die
that's the flames i think
okay yeah efficient flames
break this wall down maybe oh hello
explosives will hurt him then oh my god
my oh my god he's doing the the fasting
runny thing
slow seas will hurt him confirmed
oh oh oh oh i'm stressed if you've got a
heart rate monitor on me right now it
would be
significant this probably isn't the best
place to heal
that's what going on
[ __ ] oh no it's okay he's got terrible
aim
that might hurt a bit yeah a little bit
not too bad not too bad okay buddy
okay okay mate i hear you i hear you did
you run into the wall
no it's one of those speedy runny ones
where you just keep
there you go nope wall come on but run
into a wall
that sounds like flamethrower okay
it's like a big daddy okay
yeah come on
nope
terrible sounding cycle on this guy that
was [ __ ]
flames again
jesus okay runny thingy come on
run and get stuck in a wall put a mine
down foyo while we're at it oh god
timing
[ __ ] i don't know where he is now
did you run into a wall there you did
you did [ __ ] too slow
that's a flame okay
okay okay okay okay come on mate just
[ __ ] run into the wall please i beg
of you
i don't think i've really did that right
the music has changed no he's fine i'll
stay down
oh he's not even down yet ethan you
can't
you can't tell a man to state that was
basically a spoiler what do you mean now
stay down
he wasn't even down at all in the first
place the [ __ ] are you talking about
god i hate him can't can't stand him oh
should i go back to the duke maybe right
now because um
if i have to fight another man in the
cargo bay
i don't think i'm in a good spot
i'm just being honest
maybe okay let's check if it's
yeah yeah let's just go sell it you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was really stressful no
really got me on that one okay hey buddy
good day thank you sir i'm going to sell
you
this and buy it i will
thank you
you trying to tell me there's something
new in here
i didn't think so i'll take i'll take
i'll take it
and i'll take that
and i'll take another one of those i saw
you eyeing that and
another one of those and then i think
i've
spoiled all my money i could upgrade
that
rate of fire on that reload speed on
that what's your reload speed why
don't we this simple modification can be
done in just a moment
i maybe should have done ammo capacity
there because it would have given me
ammo but oh well
oh well i think i'll be okay
all right let's go
that really i'm like sweaty from that
endeavor that was [ __ ] stressful as
hell
i think who would have thought who would
have thunked it
not me okay
okay great okay cool what are you what
do you got for me
what do you have for me
i [ __ ] love camp fluid dude i thought
you'd never ask
i haven't even looked out the window yet
just like give me all your [ __ ]
you really wrote all that oh you did
write that maybe repeatedly maybe
over and over and over again okay well i
could go through there
my guess is that's what the video game
would like me to do this is locked
it's not locked
that's suspicious i'm gonna go this way
just in case you know there's a goat in
here
hello mate i don't mind
if i do even though i missed most of the
goats
i don't give a [ __ ] about goats there's
something else in here
this [ __ ] video game great it's just
another draw
beautiful and we should do that honestly
we could do another one okay
however you go
okay go through the grate
can't okay back out back out back out
back out
all right mate through the [ __ ] door
i feel like it's gonna make me fight
heisenberg and i don't want to
can i tell him that i think he's a king
and that i have no choice but to stand
instead
what do you think would happen if i
agree miranda sucks dick
and um we should we should be in cahoots
and i also like
this like oh but he's gonna use your
daughter as a weapon thing oh god
bro that [ __ ] is going to happen anyway
there's like almost no way it doesn't
happen
no i thought this was gonna be another
one of those things where i had to shoot
these dudes down but
i suppose not okay
i love everything that's happening right
now
ethan i'm still just really [ __ ]
upset with you dude
she can't believe
we turned on the coolest guy in the game
miranda
this is a lot of machines okay well
oh this room is already clear then okay
it's all clear am i leaving this place
now is this the first area that i
came to
um cutscene i suspect
okay heisenberg there you are
cool emo magneto
i don't want to do it i don't want to do
it
ethan i don't want to do it
ethan really [ __ ] idiot useless piece
of [ __ ]
i don't want to
i don't want it i don't want it i don't
want anything to do any of this
there is no way this doesn't [ __ ]
kill you dead as [ __ ] dude
just you think ken flew it's going to
fix that absolute death you just [ __ ]
oh my god okay if you say so
oh my um
again in reference to what in reference
to you being
a dopey sword
because i'm in agreement that's what i
think every time you say something
10 minutes too late damn it again
oh man he's so much cooler than me
this place is just called the scrap peep
okay
oh it's christ i told you to leave it
alone ethan
you are in the way that's correct yeah i
mean chris i don't have that gum though
you killed my wife you son of a [ __ ]
you think i killed mia no she's fine
that wasn't her it was miranda
what oh wait i had a baby with miranda
she changed her appearance and pretended
to be mia oh that's [ __ ] up
she also survived being shot so now i'm
here to finish the job that's ridiculous
and i love it oh [ __ ]
why don't you [ __ ] tell me right away
because i knew you would want to be
involved
and this is hard enough without
civilians getting in the way big dumb
[ __ ] yeah
that's fair actually why huss chris
what the hell is going on
all right ethan all right
i guess i owe you an explanation i feel
like i got most of it actually
i pretty much i feel like i pretty much
understood so
you don't have to really
long story short miranda's [ __ ]
insane that checks out
this village all these monsters and
freaks
this is her life's work some sort of
crazy experiment with the mold
the mold like louisiana that's what i
assumed
god damn it all this time i thought i
could save my family
i can't escape from here i can't do
anything
that might not be true
you think this thing's the answer this
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
my men sent those pictures a few minutes
ago miranda
keep looking yeah i saw her at the um
oh no rose holy [ __ ] we gotta go well
but she's not even your child
she's but they have my daughter maybe i
don't know how that works
is mia still alive against miranda by
yourself
you're gonna make me ride this stupid
tank chris
i will stay down here and finish
planting explosives you take that
elevator i'll meet you topside
okay i promise you we will get your
daughter back is she my daughter though
or is she
half miranda because if so i have less
interest
she's a dead woman
all righty she's cooler than heisenberg
though then i don't know i still i don't
want to fight him
try to stay under the radar
i'm i've killed almost everyone in this
entire town so i don't know what radar
you're referring to but i think that i
am
significantly above it if i'm
being honest um all right
you got any [ __ ] for me though statement
nice
also nice
okay cool what else are we is that it
that is it i have i feel like i have a
decision to make
the sweep of the factory is complete no
proof of any connection with the
organization guess this just wasn't our
lucky day i did manage to get my hands
on a number of documents disclosing some
of miranda's experience which support
our previous theories
she seems to have infected herself with
the mu my seat
which has granted her a number of
abilities including mimicry
to control ourselves and fam so what so
where's mia
her objective was to kidnap rose
maybe she thought she could control
rosie if she looked like a mom when we
attacked it put
a little damper on her plans so she
limited corpse
if i have to self of course she did
she still got her into those five
[ __ ] pieces somehow
okay try to figure out the noises i can
hear
they are in the game i was wondering if
they were in the real world um
all right let's [ __ ] do a cute little
save right here then shall we
and i feel like i should leave this
episode here because it seems like now
i'm heading to the end of the game
and i feel like i want that to be a
standalone so this one might be short i
don't know i know i have any concept of
how long these episodes are because i
don't check i will see you i think
probably maybe for the final part
everybody thank you for watching